c'est l'heure de notre second débat tout
de suite je vous propose de nous
projeter vers un risque connu mais
peut-être pas suffisamment anticipé
celui du inondation majeure en région
parisienne similaire à celle qui avait
paralysé la capitale en 1910 le 18
novembre dernier la Cour et la chambre
régionale des comptes pointés une
stratégie de je l'ai cite un de
prévention défaillante et des
investissements insuffisants pourtant
des chantiers ont été lancés comme en
Seine-et-Marne à La Bassée un projet qui
est assez titanesque de réservoir on est
à la confluence de la Seine et de
l'Yonne reportage Jonathan Dupriez
le chantier de la Bassée prend forme à
une heure au sud de Paris ce site de 360
hectares sera bientôt encerclé d'une
digue que l'on distingue ici en rouge à
l'intérieur un immense réservoir pour
lutter contre les crues de la Seine ou
10 millions de mètres cubes d'eau
provenant du fleuve seront stockés
temporairesment avant d'être vidangés le
temps de laisser passer le pic de cru et
de faire baisser le niveau de la Seine
ça paraît pas beaucoup
on sait baisser la ligne d'eau à Paris
10 cm ça veut dire que par exemple une
station de métro ou un bâtiment ne va
pas être inondé grâce à cette baisse de
niveau de 10 cm une fois en service le
site doit permettre de faire économiser
selon la Cour des comptes quel que 70
millions d'euros de dégâts annuels et
lorsque la retenue d'eau sera à sec elle
deviendra un lieu de promenade
accessible au public l'établissement
scène grand lac maître d'œuvre du
chantier mettant en avant son
volontarisme en matière d'écologie
vraiment le projet un double objectif un
objectif de lutte contre les inondations
et un objectif de restauration de la
biodiversité sur l'ensemble du
territoire c'est le plus gros la plus
grosse opération de restauration de
biodiversité
actuellement plus de 120 hectares vont
être restaurés mais ce chantier à 114
millions d'euros financé par l'État et
les collectivités suscite la colère de
nombreux habitants de La Bassée dans La
Bassée on a un joyau de la biodiversité
or ce projet pour moi
il va nous nous chambouler totalement
cet équilibre qu'on avait retrouvé
Véronique topato est devenu la
porte-parole des opposants depuis les
prémices elle conteste le bien-fondé du
projet avec son association
bien sûr que c'est un paysage de l'Est
de la science de son point de vue le
casier pilote est obsolète alors que la
nature a toujours ici joué son rôle dans
la régulation des crues de la Seine au
moins deux fois par an la scène sortait
de son lit
donc nous on faisait avec avec les
inondations plus personne ne veut de
projets artificiels mais Véronique
topato appuyé par l'association France
Nature Environnement dénonce surtout
l'impact sur la faune et la flore d'un
chantier qui touche une zone classée
Natura 2000 les associations ont donc
lancé des recours devant le tribunal
administratif principal point qu'il
conteste la déclaration d'utilité
publique du casier pilote qui a pu
permettre aux travaux de voir le jour
donc nous nous avons attaqué l'utilité
publique de de ce projet en disant qu'un
euro investi ne rapporte à l'école à la
collectivité
n'a pas de bénéfice pour la collectivité
c'est un bilan l'utilité publique si les
plus sont supérieurs au moins c'est de
l'utilité publique de leur côté les élus
locaux tentent comme ils peuvent de
composer avec un projet mal aimé de
leurs administrer Brice chantre et maire
de gravons 165 habitants il accueille
sur son territoire la pièce maîtresse du
casier pilote la future station de
pompage elle va apprendre tout le chenal
qui a en face
va faire à peu près un peu plus 50
mètres de diamètre et monter un
belvédère au dessus des arbres pour
pouvoir avoir des vues de là-haut en
échange Brice chantre tente d'obtenir
des compensations financières mais aussi
de petits aménagements pour sa commune
comme ce ponton si je peux obtenir des
trois petites choses pour mes
administrer ce sera très bien après
je suis encore en négociation il y a
rien de il y a rien d'acté quoi le
casier pilote de La Bassée n'est qu'une
première étape souhaitée par l'État le
projet global comporte 8 autres retenus
d'eau et pourrait voir le jour d'ici à
2035 l'objectif affiché est de réduire
jusqu'à 40 cm le niveau de la scène en
cas de crue et pour débattre autour de
cette thématique Paris la
l'Île-de-France sont-elles prêtes face à
une inondation crue décennale de type
1910 je vous présente mes invités Magali
regazza bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
maître de conférence en géographie à
l'École normale supérieure Patrick
Ollier bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
président de la métropole du Grand Paris
et président de le PTB établissement
public territorial de bassin scène grand
lac vasquen Andreas bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi hydrologue directeur de
l'unité de recherche
Icare à l'Institut national de recherche
pour l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement on est également duplex
en visioconférence avec Mary Carole sur
mer LR de Sucy-en-Brie bonsoir votre
ville à plusieurs fois été frappée par
des inondations notamment en 2018 mais
je crois que c'est assez récurrent vous
nous l'expliquerez et Laetitia cruppa
guitariste politique évidemment est
resté à mes côtés un petit coup d'oeil
historique tiens pour commencer vous
savez qu'à à Paris on se base sur le
zouave du pont de l'Alma pour pour
évaluer je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
meilleur curseur mais bref il est simple
pour évaluer le niveau des crues en 1910
en état 8 mètres 62 1926 mètres 60
ensuite il y a 24 7 mètres 32 je vais
pas tous les faire mais si on arrive à à
nos années
les années 2010 6m10 en 2016 5m 84 en
Magali regazza peut-être déjà pour
évaluer le risque d'une crue similaire à
celle de 1910 qu'est-ce qui peut
provoquer une crue pareille des semaines
et des semaines de plus c'est quoi le
il y a eu plusieurs il y a plusieurs
façons de fabriquer une crue sur ce
bassin Vincent de lassen il faut
imaginer un c'est un territoire qui fait
à peu près deux fois la Belgique ce sont
généralement les crues dont on parle ce
sont des crues lentes qui durent
plusieurs semaines la crue de 1910 elle
a duré 49 jours entre la montée et la
descente de l'eau ce sont des crues qui
effectivement généralement sont liés à
une pluviométrie un peu supérieure à la
moyenne sur l'ensemble du bassin versant
en 1957 c'est un peu différent c'était
des sols gelés qui avaient provoqué la
crue la crue de 1910 elle a une chance
sur 100 par an de se produire alors
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de crue
centenal exactement siècle c'est c'est
une chance sur 100 par an d'accord et
donc ça veut dire que un Français qui
vit en moyenne 80 ans il a deux chances
sur trois de la voir en réalité on
mesure pas justement par rapport aux
oies du pont de l'Alma qui a en plus
bougé on raisonne au niveau du pont
d'Austerlitz on a plusieurs stations de
mesure parce que selon l'endroit on va
se trouver en Île-de-France on va pas
avoir les mêmes problèmes par exemple la
banlieue est inondé beaucoup plus vite
pour des raisons topographiques par
ailleurs on a aussi une il faut pas
confondre la crue et l'inondation et ça
c'est vraiment le cœur du problème la
cru c'est un débit très élevé du cours
d'eau inondation c'est le cours d'eau de
déborde de son lit sauf que dans le cas
de la scène et de ses affluents on a un
problème particulier qui est que la
nappe phréatique va elle aussi monter et
donc en fait on va avoir une inondation
des sous-sols pour le dire autrement on
va avoir en gros des débordements qui
vont arriver assez tard en surface mais
par contre dans les sous-sols l'eau va
monter très vite et donc va inonder ses
sous-sols avec beaucoup de conséquences
évidemment on y reviendra pas très
collier la région francilienne c'est bon
on après elle est particulièrement
vulnérable au risque d'inondation c'est
quand même le premier poumon économique
français donc ça veut dire que notre
débat il concerne pas seulement les
habitants de Paris mais même pas
seulement les habitants d'Ile-de-France
on peut dire ça ah ben on peut dire plus
que ça même parce que les inondations
concernent plus de 2 millions
directement de personnes à partir de
Laval des grands lacs dont on va parler
tout à l'heure donc si d'aventure il y
avait cette crue dont parle madame ça
serait une catastrophe économique
humaine certainement mais surtout
économique imaginez qu'avec des
répercussions nationales d'une certaine
bien sûr forcément puisque c'est le
poumon économique de la France la région
parisienne imaginez que le métro
brutalement soit ravagé par une crue
imaginé simplement cela la catastrophe
que ça représenterait donc il faut tout
mettre en oeuvre dans tes programmes
d'action volontariste et dynamiques pour
l'empêcher tant que faire se peut je ne
sais pas si je verrai la crise
sentennale mais mais en tout cas le
combat que je veux mener est de faire en
sorte de de tout mettre en œuvre pour
tenter de l'empêcher un peu moins de la
limite est-ce que vous pouvez prévoir
comment vous travaillez une crue majeure
comme celle de 1970 est-ce que et si oui
à quel échéance vous dites c'est un
processus lent donc c'est quoi on peut
je vais poser vraiment une question de
aussi un peu plusieurs semaines avant
comment ça se dire attention ça a
peut-être une crue aussi grave ou alors
c'est seulement 3 jours avant qu'on se
rencontre que c'est une telle
catastrophe alors les surfaces les
services de l'État ont des services il y
a des services de prévision des crus
donc on est armé pour prévoir mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que une
prévision a très courte échéance n'a
aucun intérêt si je vous préviens c'est
trop tard si je vous préviens du
inondation dans une heure deux heures 10
heures je n'ai le temps de rien faire
dans une agglomération comme Paris donc
ce qu'il faudrait c'est des prévisions à
très longues échéances ces prévisions à
très longues échéance plusieurs semaines
elles se font mais elles ont une
incertitude immense la météo on a une
certitude à huit jours mais mais on perd
cette certitude
c'est pire que la météo parce que si on
veut prévoir les inondations longtemps à
l'avance il faut d'abord prévoir la
météo puisque l'eau des rivières lorsque
les rivières débordent c'est bien parce
qu'il y a des pluies excédentaires et
donc il faut on cumule les incertitudes
de la météo à celle de la science
hydrologique et donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'on sait faire ce que les services de
l'État savent faire avec des
incertitudes limitées mais pas sans
incertitude c'est des prévisions de
l'ordre de trois jours et en trois jours
on peut faire finalement très peu de
choses s'il s'agissait de construire
évacuer en fait les crues de la de la
scène ne tue pas grand monde il faut
savoir que il y a très peu de gens qui
meurent
il y a toujours des gens qui ont qui
prennent des risques mais mais c'est pas
on n'est pas dans les Cévennes dans la
scène par contre il y a une telle
quantité de richesses en sous-sol il y a
une telle quantité d'ouverture vers le
sous-sol vers le métro que s'il fallait
construire des digues autour de chaque
bouche de métro il nous faudrait bien
plus que trois jours et donc ces
missions impossibles donc le problème de
la prévision c'est pas que les les
hydrologues sont mauvais c'est que la
prévision c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile et incertain et
donner une prévision très incertaine le
petit nom ne sert pas à grand chose un
préfet ne sait pas et construire des
digues des aujourd'hui autour des
construire des construire et tout et
donc il faudrait il faudrait il faudrait
que chaque
usagée du métro accepte monter sur la
digue avec une échelle et de et
descendre on voit bien que c'est
impossible bon alors je vais vous donner
la parole évidemment aux uns et aux
autres on va revenir sur les dégâts
inondation pourrait provoquer mais alors
il y a quand même une question majeure
ce risque est-il suffisamment anticipé
par l'État et les collectivités locales
je propose à Quentin calmer de nous
rejoindre on va s'appuyer donc sur ce
Fanta sur un sort de la Cour des comptes
qui a été publié il y a 2 mois et qui
dresse un constat inquiétant les
différents acteurs ne sont pas prêts
voilà c'est le principal enseignement de
cette étude qui ont pu le dire et on
peut passer sous les radars peu de
médias l'ont reprises et pourtant le
constat est alarmant un risque majeur et
une gravité insuffisamment prise en
compte des actions encore limitées un
manque de stratégie de coordonnées à
l'échelle du bassin autant d'expressions
qui reviennent dans le rapport les
dernières crues les plus importantes
telles date de 2016 et de janvier 2018
on va revoir d'ailleurs les chiffres le
pic de la scène en mai 2016 on va avoir
des images plutôt le pic de la scène en
mai était donc à 6 mètres 10 au dessus
de son niveau habituel selon Vigicrues
les musées d'Orsay et du Louvre avait
fermé pour évacuer les oeuvres stockées
dans leur réserve tout comme deux sites
de la BNF janvier 2018 à Paris la crue
culmine alors à 5,85 m les Belges sont
submergés les bateaux à l'arrêt cette
garde du RER C est fermée pendant
plusieurs semaines alors pourquoi je dis
tout ça parce qu'en fait la Cour des
comptes a rappelé le coût de ces crues
mais joint en 2016 ça a coûté 1,4
milliards d'euros janvier février 2018
150 à 200 millions d'euros quant à la
cru centenal au niveau de celle de 1910
et un niveau de la scène qui serait lui
à 8 mètres 60 et bien cela causerait je
cite des dommages directs dont le coût
avoisinerait les 30 milliards d'euros
d'îles au CDE dans le rapport que l'on
avait vu alors dans un tel contexte on
s'attend évidemment à ce que les risques
d'une nouvelle crue au centre n'a été
pris en compte pas suffisamment selon le
rapport ça existe bien des outils comme
des cartes disponibles pour le grand
public sur le site de la région par
exemple je vous les conseille sur les
zones d'inondation potentielles mais
vous voyez les principaux reproches la
Cour juge qu'il faut encore renforcer la
sensibilisation de la population
francilienne deuxième point tous les
opérateurs de réseau ne sont pas prêts
au même niveau on sait qu'il y en a
beaucoup des réseaux en Île de France
électricité gaz télécommunications
transports au assainissement ils sont
pourtant très vulnérables et en première
ligne dernier point je voulais
mentionner la cour est critique sur le
pilotage de la prévention du risque état
collectivité locale opérateur de réseau
entreprise et citoyens ils doivent
davantage travailler ensemble il
n'existe pas de forums de travail sur
les sujets relatifs au risque
d'inondation de la Seine regrette ainsi
la cour contrairement à la Loire ou
encore au Rhône c'est ce qui écrit un
accord des comptes tout le monde doit
travailler ensemble à l'échelle du
bassin fluvaine ce qui n'est pas
suffisamment le cas en ce qui concerne
la scène merci Quentin pour ses
explications
Patrick Ollier la métropole du Grand
Paris est-elle prête à affronter une
crue du type de celle de 19 10 parce que
c'est un peu ce que nous dit la Cour des
comptes qui répond non à cette question
alors je vais me préparer à 1910
j'aimerais faire 2018 car je suis maire
de Rueil-Malmaison et ma ville
devreuil-malmaison en 2018 a été dans
ses bacs quartiers inondés alors la
chambre la Cour des comptes a fait un
rapport et je confirme ce rapport il est
exact et pourquoi je le confirme je
voudrais vous dire j'ai des raisons de
confirmer pourquoi parce que j'ai pris
la présidence de ce grand lac après que
le rapport était fait donc c'est à leur
scène grand lac c'est quoi tiens
établissement public qui gère les fameux
crans lac de rétention je vais en parler
si vous laissez deux minutes parce que
on peut parler des inondations on peut
parler des risques on peut parler de la
manière dont elles arrivent on peut
parler de la rapidité de réaction mais
on peut peut-être aussi parler de savoir
qu'est-ce qui est fait pour limiter au
maximum ce qu'on avait en reportage
d'ailleurs en ouverture de ce de ce
débat c'était juste une partie de ce qui
est fait non je résume ce miracle gère
les quatre lacs de rétention qui 1974
ont réaliser pour justement limiter les
inondations sur sur Paris ces quatre
grands lacs qui sont près de trois près
de Saint-Dizier le lac de Mons le lac
pansière dans le Morvan retiennent à peu
près 950 millions de mètres cubes et ils
sont chargés ils travaillent très bien
fait ils sont chargés de retenir l'eau
pour ces 850 millions au paquets
déferlent sur les régions la région
parisienne et surtout la valse des
Grands Lacs et l'été est-ce que vous
savez par exemple que cet été près de
60% de l'eau qui courait dans la Seine
venait de ses lacs
et dans la Marne c'est 70% de l'eau
j'aurais fermé les vannes des lacs les
péniches et les bateaux-mouches
n'auraient plus naviguer il faut aussi
savoir ce qui se passe là au niveau du
climat les conséquences que ça donc ces
grands lacs fonctionnent très bien et le
PTB c'est une grande laque a bien fait
son travail le problème c'est que il
aurait fallu faire plus et que nous nous
sommes engagés depuis que j'ai pris la
présidence en jumulant la métropole des
grands Paris vous allez voir pourquoi
Essen gras lac a réalisé deux actions
complémentaires la première c'est ce que
on a vu sur le reportage le casier
pilote de La Bassée parce que nous avons
dans l'idée de faire 8 l'axe
supplémentaires autour de la
Seine-et-Marne mais on commence par un
casier pilote pour voir si ça fonctionne
on voit que la population localement en
tout cas il y a des réticences
il y a une personne qui a effectivement
illégitime je la comprends très bien sa
place je ferai pareil les propriétaires
du casque notre journaliste qui était
sur place dit moi j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de gens qui qui disent on a
l'impression de payer pour Paris
quand je vais à Auxerre ou à
Château-Chinon aussi non non mais on
peut pas faire comme si ça n'existait
pas
la personne en question elle est
légitime dans sa réaction j'ai pas la
critiqué elle est propriétaire du car de
du terrain qu'on exproprie donc on peut
comprendre sa réaction légitime c'est
pas de ça dont je parlais ce casier
pilote va retenir 10 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau il sera terminé pour les
Jeux Olympiques elle a pris l'engagement
de le terminer c'est pour ça qu'on veut
commencer les travaux très vite et il
diminuera sur Paris et les villes de
menacées autour de Paris de 15 cm d'eau
par rapport à la CRI à la crue 2018 donc
c'est extrêmement important pour nous
troisième action et pour baisser de 40
cm il faut en faire 8 autres c'est ça
c'est ce que j'ai compris 40 cm de plus
ouais
ça fait 10 15 + les 70 dégradés le lac
alors je voulais pas non parce que j'ai
plutôt mis de la confusion de l'histoire
je vous laisse conclure
ça m'arrive les quatre Grands Lacs La
Bassée ça fait deux et je veux lancer
une nouvelle action qui est lancée ça y
est c'est des zones d'expansion des
crues tout le long de la scène de la
Marne et de l'Yonne pour ça que je fais
des réunions à Saint-Dizier à Auxerre
etc à Troyes pour que les maîtres
d'ouvrage potentiels les EPCI les
intercommunalités le long ils peuvent
être maître d'ouvrage accepte de lancer
des travaux pour ces zones d'expansion
qu'est-ce que c'est que des zones
d'expansion très vite c'est oui mais
c'est ça qui va sauver peut-être Paris
la région parisienne ce sont des zones
qui permettent des surinations des
terrains agricoles l'eau rentre elle
peut pas ressortir ce qui fait qu'elle
défale pas sur Paris et ça ne peut se
faire que si les agriculteurs
l'acceptent et la métropole du Grand
Paris vient dans le cas de ces travaux
permettre de financer l'indemnisation
des agriculteurs ça change tout parce
qu'ils acceptent inondations de leur
terrain je vous interrompre
vous voulez savoir ce qu'on fait quand
la prise de parole est longue quand même
projets qui vont être terminés dans les
50 qui viennent alors on va voir ce que
vous en pensez les uns les autres mais
on a un milliard de mètres cubes d'eau
de plus on n'a pas entendu encore la
mère LR de Sucy-en-Brie qui s'appelle
marie-carol siuntu rebons soit merci de
votre patience quand vous entendez
Patrick Ollier voilà vanter le travail
fait par la métropole du Grand Paris et
Seine grand lacs est-ce que voilà vous
vous sentez concerné comment ça se passe
dans une ville comme la vôtre je disais
qu'il y a eu plusieurs
inondations finalement un peu
récurrentes
oui alors nous depuis 2016 on découvre
en fait que sans avoir la scène sans
avoir la marde on a simplement un
affluent de la Marne et bien on est
inondé à raison de tous les deux ans de
manière plus en plus grave parfois
consécutifs comme en 2021 on a été
inondérée nous par vague successives
alors la métropole du Grand Paris a pris
récemment la compétence Patrick collier
connaît bien notre territoire il y était
récemment il a fait des études
approfondie et c'est la première fois
qu'on l'a sur justement ces
comportements des affluents de la Marne
et nous ce qui nous fait effectivement
peur c'est qu'on n'a pas des besoins
aussi grands pour trouver des solutions
c'est que finalement nos villes de
banlieue et bien on n'est pas la même
attention vis-à-vis d'elle et que aussi
des gros événements des des dates comme
ça phares où il va falloir pouvoir se
baigner dans la scène ou dans la Marne
avec les Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent
nous prive totalement de moyens quand
justement la métropole a pris un travail
important arrive dans le dur et dit
voilà ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
mettre à l'abri des quartiers entiers de
nos communes des risques d'inondations
qui sont récurrents et tout le monde le
reconnaît de plus en plus fréquent et de
plus en plus grave voilà la réaction qui
est représentative d'un certain nombre
de maires qui ont les mêmes
problématiques c'est d'être oubliés
parce que justement il n'y a pas que la
Crum 1910 et les risques dont vous venez
de parler et on a également des besoins
ça rejoint un peu la critique dont je
parlais tout à l'heure chez certains
habitants à La Bassée là où on a un état
reportage tout à l'heure qui disent on
paye pour Paris est-ce que vos
administrés vous disent ça aussi de
temps en temps
on a moi je ne dis pas que ce qui est
fait n'est pas nécessaire mais ce qu'on
se dit plutôt c'est est-ce qu'il y a une
politique au niveau de l'Île-de-France
qui prend en compte les sujets de nos
communes c'est plutôt ça c'est pas on
paye pour Paris le problème il existe de
toute façon les sujets sont liés mais
est-ce que nous nous avons une
visibilité et la métropole en
inconscience puisque justement elle a
très vite pris en charge le problème de
notre commune
Magalie regazza
rapidement merci vous avez été
auditionné par la Cour des comptes pour
ce rapport dont nous parler Quentin
Calmet donc je rappelle je recite un qui
pointe un manque de stratégie
coordonnées est-ce qu'il y a trop
d'acteurs concernés est-ce qu'il y a
voilà est-ce qu'il faut centraliser
parce que on a bien compris quand on
entend la mer d'une commune comme si
c'est vrai que la dimension d'une comme
celle-là elles peuvent quasiment rien
faire elle a besoin de la puissance
publique il se trouve que moi j'ai fait
ma thèse en 2006 sur les inondations et
que c'est un sujet qui est en
Île-de-France depuis des années les
premières études elles commencent dans
les années 80 donc de dire qu'on savait
pas il faut quand même pas exagérer il
nous reste en Île-de-France dans les
zones tout a été en gros il me reste
plus que 10 % moins de 10 % des zones
qui n'ont pas été construites ça c'est
la réalité donc il y a quand même un
moment où des permis de construire ont
été accordés dans des zones qui étaient
des zones inondables ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point et je suis
désolé de le dire nous n'empêcherons pas
une crue de la scène et qui va alors une
crue de sandale ou même une crue 59
comme celle de 55 ça n'est pas possible
parce qu'effectivement on est sur 850
millions de de litres pour le 2 mètres
cubes pardon sur les sur les Grands Lacs
on est à plusieurs milliards quand on va
arriver sur les travaux qui ont été
faits et même ceux qui sont lancés ne
suffiront pas c'est ce que ça ne suffira
pas par contre et c'est ce qui a été dit
dans le reportage c'est très important
parce que on a effectivement parfois des
centimètres quelques centimètres c'est
plusieurs millions d'euros d'économiser
pour faire simple il faut redonner des
des ordres de grandeur ce qu'on a eu en
quand on parle de 2018 ou de 2016 ce
sont de toutes petites crues et non
totalement de mi-joint c'est une crue
rapide du loin qui a dévasté
Souppes-sur-Loing qui a dévasté Nemours
on n'est pas du tout sur ce qui se passe
sur une crue comme 2018 où on est en
hiver la crue de 2018 elle est à 5
mètres l'eau elle monte en gros de 50 cm
à 1 mètre par jour et comme on vous l'a
dit ce qu'on peut dire c'est demain ça
monte ou ça descend après demain ça
monte ou ça descend dans 3 jours je sais
pas il faut mettre en place
effectivement des plans là encore un
chiffre c'est 400 ouvertures rien que
sur le métro à bouger vous ne pouvez pas
évacuer par exemple des maisons de
retraite des hôpitaux il faut plusieurs
jours pour le faire les premiers
dommages apparaissent à 6 mètres 50 la
crue centenal c'est 8 mètres 60 quels
sont les premiers dommages alors les
premiers dommages ce sont hommage au
réseau alors les premiers dommages
premiers dommage ce sont les communes
périphériques les communes de banlieue
Val-de-Marne notamment 92 ensuite qui
vont d'abord avoir des remontées de
nappes dans les caves donc des
effondrements de réseau des remontées
d'assainissement quand vous avez une
remontée d'assainissement donc j'ai
d'évacué donc ça c'est même avant que la
scène soit sortie de Paris il n'y aura
pas une goutte d'eau dans Paris à 6
mètres 50 il n'y a pas d'eau dans Paris
et pourtant les réseaux commencent à
tomber à 7 mètres on est dans une
paralysie possible de l'agglomération
pourquoi parce que il faut que
préventivement tous les acteurs la RATP
ferme des places bouche il faut déplacer
par exemple les personnes âgées vous
avez le chauffage urbain qui risque de
tomber vous avez aussi des problèmes au
niveau de l'alimentation des
distributeurs dès que votre cavette
inondé il y a plus d'électricité et ce
qui est compliqué dans cette inondation
c'est que oh elle ne se voit pas en tout
cas dans Paris et dans les lieux qu'on
voit deux c'est qu'effectivement c'est
cette inondation en sous-sol qui va
aussi affaiblir des bâtiments dont vous
allez avoir des des effets dominos et
trois et ça c'est aussi important à le
dire ce n'est pas parce que vous n'avez
pas les pieds dans l'eau que vous n'êtes
pas touché vous pouvez habiter en étage
vous pouvez habiter dans des endroits
qui sont éloignés de la scène par ses
effets de vases communicants par ces
effets en fait de réseau et de
dépendance au réseau vous avez une
perturbation qui arrive c'est une panne
généralisée pour que nos concitoyens se
l'imaginent là encore juste deux
chiffres c'est la crise covid le
confinement ces deux mois c'est le même
ce qui s'est passé pendant le
confinement nous en fait en tant que
chercheur ça nous avait beaucoup frappé
parce que c'est exactement le scénario
duquel la scène sauf que les raisons ont
obtenu
on peut rester chez nous mais ensuite à
la différence du confinement c'est que
ça se rallume pas il va falloir
deuxièmement on a parlé de 30 milliards
en réalité c'est 100 milliards d'euros
s'il vous plaît les dégâts immédiats au
bâti aurait on compte pas les à partir
de quel niveau d'eau on commence à être
vraiment dans une situation compliquée à
partir de 6 mètres 50 et 7 mètres cette
même 50 là on arrive à des choses très
difficiles et quand on parlait de mort
il faut faire attention risque
d'incendie mais surtout des déplacements
de personnes âgées des déplacements de
personnes malades en fait vous avez des
conséquences en chaîne avec une
surmortalité qui arrive j'ai été
mauvaise élève Thomas mais là on est à
combien alors du coup aujourd'hui ce que
6 mètres 50 vous nous dites c'est là où
tout bascule on est très bas on est la
scène en temps normal elle coule entre
un médecin quand même voilà on inonde
les voies sur berges à 3 mètres 3 mètres
40 donc c'est très peu en fait c'est une
échelle de référence qui qui joue au la
référence au pont d'Austerlitz qui nous
dit c'est pas c'est pas l'altitude par
rapport au niveau de la mer mais la
ville de Paris aujourd'hui elle est
beaucoup plus vulnérable aux résidents
que la Ville de Paris 1910 c'est-à-dire
que parce qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
réseau voilà donc donc tout simplement
on parle des on peut faire le métro par
exemple qu'est-ce que ça signifie si le
métro commence à être à être inondé
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah il faut le
fermer ça c'est sûr il faut le fermer et
puis et ensuite il faut évacuer l'eau et
une fois que vous avez évacué l'eau
toutes les aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
métro lorsqu'il fonctionne enfin il y a
des il y a des réseaux et des sécurités
en fait tout il y a toutes
l'électronique électronique n'aime pas
l'eau et elle n'est pas
insubersible électronique du métro donc
en fait il faut tout changer tout tout
donc en fait la fermeture du métro c'est
pas aussi hein parce qu'il y a pas que
le métro et donc le métro il faudra des
années des années pour réparer cette
année pour réparer alors il y a une
question d'investissement et c'est là
que ça devient intéressant et je me
tourne de nouveau ouvert vers vous
Patrick collier parce que on peut se
dire mais c'est bon ben voilà c'est
c'est pas arrivé depuis 1910 combien
d'argent on va dépenser pour une crue
aussi hypothétique vous voyez ce que je
veux dire sauf que Maggie et raisin nous
dit ça va coûter 100 milliards
donc jusqu'où on investit et une et la
métropole Grand Paris est prête à
investir pour protéger les concitoyens
de ce risque d'abord je voudrais
répondre sur le fait que personne
s'occupe de rien et qui a pas de
coordination c'est faux c'est faux il y
a un comité de bassin c'est ce que dit
la Cour des comptes peut-être que c'est
moi
en compte probablement l'existence du
comité de bassin ou régulièrement tous
les trois mois il y a une rayon en
préfecture de région avec tous les
acteurs du bord des fleuves qui se
coordonnent dans leurs activités
premièrement deuxièmement pour ce que
vous dites par rapport au risque je
comprends très bien tout cela mais les
scènes grands lac a lancé des des
comment il s'appelle quand on met en
place des
des simulations d'inondations pour
pouvoir se préparer au risque car elle a
fait le premier dans ma ville de
Rueil-Malmaison des exercices de
simulation et on va le faire dans toutes
les villes concernées en réunissant tous
les acteurs les acteurs sociaux les
EHPAD etc lors des comités de prévention
qui ont des plans de sauvegarde que nous
écrivons noir sur blanc avec une
programmation qui fait que si d'aventure
malheureusement ça arrive immédiatement
il y a des réactions qui sont faites ça
veut dire qu'on se prépare pas 1910 moi
je ne suis pas capable de prévoir alors
on me dites sauf que c'est une hypothèse
bien sûr 910 et moi je suis pas
augmentent chaque année j'imagine non
pas forcément on augmente les
probabilités n'augmentent pas la seule
chose qu'on peut dire c'est que
elle va se reproduire cette crue c'est
juste sur il suffit d'attendre
suffisamment longtemps et on a aucune
idée de camp et le fait qu'elle se soit
introduit depuis 100 ans ne nous dit pas
mais qu'elle va et donc on est au cœur
du débat Patrick Ollier est-ce qu'on
doit dépenser énormément d'argent pour
encore une fois vous dites 1910 ça ne me
concerne pas mais si ça nous concerne
l'hypothèse l'hypothèse d'une crue aussi
puissante pas je veux dire ce que madame
a dit que certainement vrai je suis pas
un scientifique qu'on ne pourra rien
faire comme une crue contre une crue de
1910 c'est ce que vous dites moi je ne
suis pas capable d'apprécier cela je dis
simplement que ce que nous faisons nous
les élus ces migrants là qui est la
métropole la métropole en rémunérant les
agriculteurs qui acceptent que le nom de
leur terre c'est de limiter au maximum
par notre programme de zone
d'exploitation de crue les ravages fait
sur les 2 millions de personnes
concernées par le palais inondations
2016-2018 au dessus de là si nous
faisons les 8 autres lacs de rétention
après le casier pilote de La Bassée on
gagne encore 70 cm mais ça résoudra pas
1910 non plus d'autres options pour
mieux nous protéger d'une d'une crue
centenal en fait il faut changer de
logiciel puisque c'est l'expression à la
mode effectivement ce qui a été dit
c'est que il faut gagner du temps et
donc c'est grand là qui permettent
actuellement aussi fonctionnent comme il
faut parce que là aussi avec le
changement climatique ils peuvent être
plein pour préparer les tirages de l'été
au moment où la CRU arrive c'est 70 cm
si on ajoute ensuite les casiers de La
Bassée juste pour petite information La
Bassée ça a commencé en 90 ans on a
commencé à en parler en 90 les premières
études sur la scène c'était pour savoir
s'il fallait construire de nouveaux lacs
donc c'est très conflictuel il est PTB
d'envoyer le temps les cours augmentés
et le PTB a fait un gros travail de
terrain là aussi pourra travailler mais
pourquoi parce que parce qu'il y avait
des oppositions locales c'est ça parce
qu'il y avait des oppositions parce
qu'on n'envoyait pas l'intérêt parce
qu'il faut être propriété tout ça elle a
décharge de Monsieur Ollier les choses
sont séparées sur l'île de France c'est
à dire que la métropole elle gère par
exemple les digues avec la compétence
hémapi la gestion de crise c'est du
ressort de la préfecture de zone
c'est-à-dire de la préfecture de police
et puis quand vous êtes sur la
prévention alors ça dépend parce qu'il y
a des actions de prévention qui sont
faites par les départements il y a des
actions de prévention qui sont faites
par les par exemple par le PTB en
pratique la solution qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est quoi c'est de se préparer en 2016
on a eu un grand exercice européen qui
s'appelait c'est quoi nappe pour la
première fois on a fait jouer sur le
territoire 80 acteurs publics et privés
ça a coûté 2 millions d'euros et cet
exercice à côté 2 millions d'euros ça
paraît beaucoup par rapport à 30
milliards ça a permis de préparer les
acteurs pour la crue de joie et en
jouant on s'est déjà passé bon on a
réglé le problème je vais vous laisser
conclure là dessus je vous propose tiens
un élément c'est justement le le préfet
chargé du secrétaire général de la zone
de défense et de sécurité le préfet
Jean-Paul Kim qui avait supervisé en
quelque sorte si j'ai bien compris cet
exercice de simulation on est un temps
mars 2016 donc on est quoi deux trois
mois avant la crue dont on parlait tout
à l'heure voilà ce qu'il dit sur voilà
la capacité à réagir face à un phénomène
comme celui-là quelle est notre
stratégie
objective rétablir le plus rapidement
possible l'activité sur le territoire
francilien qu'est-ce qu'on privilégie
par quoi faut-il commencer quels sont
les axes à déblayer d'abord ou faut-il
rétablir l'existence priorité voilà il
nous dit que c'est une phénomène
inévitable on peut le retarder avec tous
les moyens techniques on saura jamais
qu'elle sera le niveau de cette crue
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis 2016
est-ce qu'on a pu j'espère tirer les
leçons de
gilet jaune au fond on était en état
observateur on se quitte en se disant
c'est bon on se revoit l'année prochaine
en juin la CRU arrive et là on est
surpris puis après tout le monde lui dit
bon bah c'est très bien ça s'est bien
passé et puis bah on va faire un club
c'est quoi non on va essayer de mettre
ça et puis ça s'est arrêté et ça s'est
arrêté 2018 est arrivé c'était plutôt la
banlieue donc il y a pas mal de choses
qui ont été faites d'ailleurs sur des
territoires de banlieue inondés de
manière récurrente et puis d'une
certaine manière l'actualité il y a eu
les attentes il y avait les attentat il
y a eu il y a eu d'autres sujets qui
sont arrivés il y a eu covid et d'une
certaine façon ces exercices de
préparation ils se sont maintenus on a
eu des exercices mais on a plus cette
cette capacité à faire à faire vraiment
au niveau métropolitain la spécificité
de cet exercice c'est qu'il était sur 15
jours et qu'on a joué en temps réel la
montée de l'eau et ça a été très
important et on a une difficulté sur
cette île de France c'est que
malheureusement on a beaucoup de mal à
capitaliser les préfets changent très
vite les fonctionnaires dans les
administrations forgent très vite on
sait ceux qui sont à la main à
l'intérieur par exemple à RATP la RATP
on en parle on en a parlé depuis 96 la
RATP a un plan extrêmement au point
extrêmement en avance on a des
opérateurs qui prennent à peine les
choses en marche l'assainissement par
exemple en 2018 le SSIAP je vous ai dit
là c'est dispo c'est vraiment un point
central ils ont mené une étude de
vulnérabilité donc on avance mais un
moment donné il faut bien comprendre que
ce qu'on arrivera pas à prévenir il va
falloir le gérer et cette gestion là
elle demande d'avoir
un entraînement une montée en compétence
que disait le préfet kill moi qui m'a
beaucoup marqué quand j'ai travaillé sur
ces sujets on la gestion de crise est un
métier et sur des événements comme ça on
peut atténuer la crise comme pour le
changement climatique on ne pourra pas
l'empêcher il faut l'atténuer au maximum
je vous donne la parole parce que depuis
3 ans les collectivités territoriales
ont justement à leur disposition un kit
de communication en cas de crue de la
scène et de la Marne et c'est grâce à
votre organisme Patrick Ollier donc vous
allez prendre la parole à nouveau pour
nous expliquer et nous chanter oui en
fait c'est intéressant ce kit de
communication finalement c'est arrivé
après l'incendie de Lubrizol
rappelez-vous en septembre 2019
1500 collectivités territoriales ont
reçu un mail avec un kit de
communication en fonction des supports
par exemple si vous devez faire un
communiqué de presse c'est pas la même
chose que si vous devez communiquer sur
les réseaux sociaux donc je vous propose
pendant que je vous parle de voir ces
vidéos parce que il y a des vidéos à
destination des particuliers des vidéos
à destination des entreprises des
messages aussi qui ont été proposés aux
collectivités territoriales et puis des
éléments de langage savoir quoi dire à
quel moment de la crue avant pendant
puis après
je me tourne vers Marie Carole sinto
est-ce que vous vous l'utilisez ce kit
comment vous puisque malheureusement
dans votre ville il y a des il y a des
inondations des crues régulières comment
vous est-ce que vous l'utilisez alors
d'abord bien sûr que on apprend à être
un territoire qui doit vivre avec les
inondations ça les habitants le
comprennent très bien qu'il faut pas
nier l'existence de la nature et que le
risque zéro n'existe pas mais nous
justement on revendique d'être
territoire résilient d'avoir des
aménagements qui conviennent et c'est là
où aussi les politiques de l'État là
sont très contradictoires puisque comme
vous disiez madame il y a encore des
territoires inondables qui ne sont pas
totalement
construit et nous on nous on est très
mal puisque c'est l'État qui sur un
territoire qui est à New yeen nous
oblige à continuer à raisonner à
vraiment de manière inappropriée comme
il y a 25 ans alors même qu'aujourd'hui
grâce à la métropole et à des études
pour que nous devenions territoire
résilient nous demandons effectivement
avoir une population qui s'habituent à
vivre avec les inondations mais à qui on
propose aussi de d'être aménagé et
d'avoir des constructions qui
conviennent au risque que l'on connaît
alors il y a la question de l'alerte et
je veux bien vous entendre là-dessus
parce que c'est très bien d'avoir des
dispositifs d'alerte sauf qu'il faut les
utiliser à bon escient c'est ça pas
parce qu'une alerte ça peut coûter de
l'argent aussi ou une fausse alerte en
fait si on donne si on le problème de
l'alerte c'est un peu le problème de
l'enfant qui criait au loup si on veut
être on veut éviter le plus possible de
manquer un événement de manquer une
il faut crier au loup très souvent si on
crée au loup trop souvent on est plus
crédible on finit par plus donc en fait
nous concitoyens peut y faire donc en
fait c'est c'est extrêmement complexe on
a l'impression que c'est on a
l'impression que c'est simple et on a
l'impression que même envoyer des
messages éventuellement exagéré exagéré
ça résoudra les problèmes au moins les
gens auront été prévenus etc moi je
pense que c'est faux parce que il faut
pas prendre les nos concitoyens pour des
pour des pour des enfants si on les
trompe un certain nombre de fois ou
s'ils ont l'impression qu'on se trompe
ils n'ont pas tous la capacité à
apprécier les difficultés de notre
métier d'hydrologue ou les incertitudes
donc c'est c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
compliqué l'alerte donc faut il faut
être très sérieux avec ça moi je pense
que parmi les choses qui sont qui
manquent vraiment ce sont les exercices
au Japon il y a des tremblements de
terre tous les ans dans les écoles au
Japon on fait des exercices pour préparé
au tremblement de terre tous les ans et
c'est grâce à cette capacité à cette à
cette répétition tous les ans qu'on a
que le Japon est très résilié par
rapport aux tremblements en France des
exercices contre les attaques
terroristes alors oui mais c'est sans
doute utile mais il faudrait ajouter
cette dimension inondation et ça
pourrait avoir être comment dirais
éducatif également oui je veux dire que
monsieur a tout à fait raison et nous
avons assez agréable pardon de parler de
la boutique
qui s'appelle épicène c'est un système
d'information vous devez connaître qui
est effectivement est destiné au sachant
c'est à dire aux élus à ceux qui sont et
qui permet d'avoir des informations en
permanence sur le niveau des crus etc
etc passons là dessus j'ai voulu et là
c'est récent puisque on a commencé par
ma ville il y a deux mois faire un
exercice de préparation des crues avec
un comité de pilotage décrue dans chaque
commune concernée sur tous les parcours
des trois fleuves concernés l'Yonne la
Marne et la Seine c'est à dire de Paris
en remontant jusque jusque aux sources
et on a commencé et on va les développer
donc chaque mère est responsable et on
fait on a un protocole il y a une
procédure qui est écrite sur blanc et
tous les acteurs reçoivent cette
procédure et si d'aventure vous nous
donnez l'alerte immédiatement ils savent
ce qu'il faut faire c'est déjà quelque
chose qui est performant c'est qu'en
fait toutes les collectivités
territoriales comme elles ont reçu le
même kit vont le faire vont envoyer des
messages au même moment là on parle pas
de kit là maintenant on va plus loin que
le kit on va des exercices exercices sur
le thème sur le terrain on va même par
exemple jusqu'à construire les
passerelles métalliques ils sont censés
passer au dessus pour de l'eau pour
aller dans un autre de la rue avec
toutes les habitants vous le faites les
habitants sont invités à venir bien sûr
on va le faire sur tout le long des
fleuves puisque personne ne le fait le
PTB va le faire voilà donc on a bien
compris une crue centenal type 1910 on
peut pas s'en protéger totalement il
faut l'anticiper il faut faire plus de
d'exercice ou de ou de séquences comme
celle qui avait été faite en 2016 moi
j'ai question à vous poser en a parlé
2024 imaginons que en janvier 2024 il y
a une crue majeure à Paris est-ce qu'on
peut organiser les JO non vous dites NON
il y aura eu trop de dégâts de toute
façon ça sera même pas sec c'est à dire
que en août 2010 enfin 1910 pardon les
caves étaient encore humide ça veut dire
pomper ça veut dire ça ne sera pas
possible il faut quand même se rendre
compte que derrière par exemple pour
chaque immeuble qui a été privé de
courant même si le transfert le poste
marche il faut que immeuble par immeuble
on vient de vérifier la stabilité de
l'immeuble et qu'ensuite on vient de
rebrancher le courant ça veut dire que
par exemple les voies ferrées qui ont
été inondées le ballast est parti il
faut le remettre donc si vous voulez on
est sur des crises qui sont majeures moi
je pense aussi beaucoup aux entreprises
on en a pas du tout parlé on a un tissu
très très fort de PME PMI qui ne peuvent
pas se préparer face à ces événements
les grands groupes se préparent pas ces
PME PMI on revient encore dans la
logique covid pensons aussi à ces
travailleurs de deuxième ou troisième
ligne comme on les a appelé on a des tas
aujourd'hui de gens qui font fonctionner
la vie économique de notre pays parce
qu'en réalité quand il faut fonctionner
la vie économique de l'Île-de-France ils
font fonctionner la vie du pays ils ne
pourront pas tout simplement venir
travailler des choses toutes bêtes
aujourd'hui les policiers qui
travaillent à Paris ils habitent pas à
Paris les enseignants qui travaillent à
Paris n'habitent pas Paris les soignants
n'habitent pas Paris vu le prix du mètre
carré c'est pas possible donc ça veut
dire en fait derrière qu'on est dans une
situation compliquée et que
on a besoin d'un portage vraiment plus
fort au niveau cette fois-ci national
parce que c'est un sujet qui est
national merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau et depuis la mairie de
Sucy-en-Brie évidemment je vous dis à
demain sur public Senna et votre
prochain rendez-vous politique l'ancien
ministre du Travail Éric Woerth sera
l'invité de rayonnementcini demain matin
8h évidemment on va parler de la réforme
des retraites
[Musique]